well the war is also having a big impact
on health care more widely of course in
ukraine and with modern drugs people
with hiv live long full healthy lives
but without those drugs their health and
very lives are at stake now ukraine has
got some of the highest prevalence rates
of hiv in the world outside of africa as
much as one percent of the entire
population has the virus and it was
already struggling with the burden of
hiv now of course with drug supplies
disrupted after the invasion support for
those living with hiv tb and other
serious conditions has effectively
collapsed
we're joined now by the alliance for
public health executive director andre
klepikov you were based in kiev you're
now in la viv in the west of the country
thank you for being with us
it's always so critical for us to hear
from people on the ground in ukraine and
we've seen these horrific images this
morning
of what's happened to civilians can you
just start by giving us a sense of the
situation
on the ground in ukraine and what people
are witnessing
good morning yes uh situation is very uh
terrible because we saw a huge tragedy
in in bucha in the kiev sabah
russians
actually practice genocide killing
men between the age of 18 and 16.
and of course uh if we are talking about
people with hiv with tb people who use
drugs they were vulnerable even in a
normal life so during the war their
vulnerability increased by times
and most of the people living with hiv
actually located an eastern and southern
part of ukraine uh affected the war the
most
as you say you know ukraine has got very
serious hiv epidemic i think more than
250 000 people living with the virus
just give us a sense of how difficult it
is to get these crucial drugs to those
who need them
uh it is a very challenging task because
in the areas directly affected by the
war uh
over 100 000 people with hiv are living
59 000 out of them are receiving
antiretroviral treatment
so it's not only governmental
agencies medical facilities but also
ngos like mine uh delivering irv drugs
to the patients
it is difficult and it's very
challenging because we are continuing to
do this events in the occupied
territories
it's dangerous and just couple of days
ago
our partner organization faced situation
where
a van with volunteers delivering
medicines and humanitarian aid was
shelled and two people unfortunately
died
really awful to hear that
aid workers people who are delivering
essential medical supplies coming under
fire can you give us a bit more
information about what happened with
that attack or is it impossible for you
to do so
uh it was
attack intentional attack because
clearly
there was
clearly not a military convoy it was
humanitarian convoy it was clearly
visible
and it was attacked on the way to convoy
to chernigev
that's the situation our partner
organization faced and this is our van
which was destroyed but uh destructions
are huge over all
over all
areas including marijuana where
all
locations were destroyed to to dust
actually to nothing clinics in nicolai
were destroyed in kharkiv in the zoom
which was already mentioned uh
by
mp colleague from ukraine
terrible things are going on and
civilians medical personnel social
workers are suffering more and more from
this war
have you been able to get supplies into
mario paul and i think there are almost
5 000 people living with hiv there or is
the situation just too difficult and too
dangerous to get those supplies in
uh unfortunately russian forces
don't allow to go in so we helped those
patients who managed to escape and now
move to nipro or the parisia or other
locations
but unfortunately access to mariupol is
so difficult we are helping some people
even known with hiv but for example
suffers from this uh terrible attack on
on
on shelter uh
located in theater
it wasn't the news and uh
there were terrible stories so we help
people to evacuate from from there hiv
positive and not hiv positive we in this
situation we are helping everyone
yeah you're in the business of saving
lives right so that's what you do as a
organization such as yourself
what stories are you hearing from the
people that you are meeting in these
desperate situations
needs of people uh increased
substantially
now they're requiring not only
medications but also
food
housing or shelter
some support psychological support
mental health support
so
we need more resources
and we are having this
appeal hosted by organization frontline
aides so
please call in to everyone to support us
with with checking the website
frontlineaids.org
donate
it's important to provide uh more
resources because so far our resources
are limited and we are working in all
provinces of ukraine
uh
more than
with 100
local organizations based on the ground
how many people are at risk of running
out of the drugs that they need and as a
result can you put any
figure on the number of lives that could
be at risk
uh risk is very high it's the highest i
think in the world so if we are talking
about uh
hiv patients as i said uh 59 000
people are on irt in the areas affected
by the war and uh
less than uh 40 percent managed to move
outside uh of of these war zones so we
are talking about uh
tens of thousands of people at risk
we use different uh modalities to
deliver drugs where it's possible
through mobile vents through smaller
delivery even through
mail where it's possible
but the key things is the logistics
because uh unfortunately in some places
like to mario paul
access is restricted
tens of thousands of people at risk
thank you for coming on the program and
speaking so powerfully
it's one of those consequences of the
war isn't it that perhaps you may not
initially think about but so many lives
at stake so thank you for coming on
the programme today